купіть але ми тазу зустрічі російської
президента володимира путіна та угорського
прем'єра віктора орбана масштабний
стильний бізнес і дайте про постачання
газу до смутку буде містеру з атомом
блоки в ас і профінансують і
російської деш банк та
то вчись у вощини у газових проектах
Однак експерти поважаю щедра
путін і арбо призначеного найживіший
політичний резонанс
адже їй за зустрічі після анексії криму
і Петро img росію провини на донбасі путін
і рідкісні сни є в Європі арбо нашу не
матч вони нерідко називають піду але і шляхи
на в'їзд і слідами нам приходили
компасу оньїсанти сам і там у тебе за
стригти наздогнав його житлового для Росії
обидва шляхи орбан важливий його і для путіна
як лідер європейської України ще стоїть у
позиції до брюсселя свист та русі
затікала на чому європейський союзний buff
політичним засланцем
особливо його за розкол і відривають дебати
ще до санкцій Росії важливий його мотай
про пічника в Європі але жив його на
видосі я прочитаю батоги скошування санкцій
навіщо орбан душі перекладаючий партнер
до 2014 уроку партнером Росії у звуть
було не менше на санту від своєї
доглянутого 3 травня економічно вигоду біт
проекті дорослішають, а я ще причиною
довезу зустрічі пояснюю вольський
політолог поттер міцно інтерв'ю
німецькому шпигу лю
Путін поважав його продуманий суворо ти я до
сину євросоюз розвіддані харчування
санкцій декор банді сваху боку хотів
б показати ще Росія серйозну Петро
йому панщину ще в нових міжнародних
умовах засіки якщо броня трампа всього
вже на треба срамота sea-pro t чий голос
втрачено на стиль кого go маму євросоюзі
ще мото серйозним клубне нічого не в
випробування скошування santee зближення з
росією в експертів на ім'я дні днів
пам'ятаєш закономірному рощина до сліз
лобка і багато в чому у заручника
Євросоюзу для засмучений його жив його ще й
храму діана за дикий відкритий ринок
працюйте вищих виключно на has the moon та
можна сказати ще кулі 1000 покличте
прибирача настінно сильно в одне
чесного орда забувати ще овочі на
їжі наклеєна сика виступає за
завантаження санте ще до Росії
схожі на вістря втомимося годиною з ліжка
разом з та на європейських crying
цілющі засіки слова china чехії то
болгарія